you doing wonderful can you do me a
favor just put it in part for me and
make sure the doors are unlocked I can
Dwayne Johnson gets pulled over wow
that's crazy and let's just say the
officer got a free ticket to the gun
show that's why you got to do it the
actors sharing his recorded interaction
with the police outside an XFL Stadium
seemingly part of a routine Security
check doing wonderful can you do me a
favor just put it in part for me and
make sure the doors are unlocked I can
but Dwayne couldn't resist a golden
opportunity to make a dad joke I got a
lot of guns in this okay please kind
it's always room for a cheesy joke I
know you're welcome
I have an arms day chest day neck day
the action star notes in the caption
it's a horrible joke but impeccable
timing he also praises the officers
writing all love gratitude and respect
for our men and women keeping us all
safe I thought it was a cool moment
that I wanted to share Jokes Aside it
seems like Dwayne's in good spirits just
weeks after his mother otta Johnson was
involved in a severe car accident
whatever it is you do it always comes
down to family and the loved ones that
you have so I'm really blessed the
Jumanji star shared this photo of The
Red Cadillac she was driving the front
of the SUV completely crushed but
thankfully his mom made it out unscathed
I gotta ask you how your mama is How's
Mama thank you she's doing really good I
appreciate that Jerry moment it was a
scary moment that was 3 A.M when I get
that phone call and you know we know
when that phone rings at 3am and it's a
family member it's not good so luckily
she had the wits about her to call
she put the paramedics on and I said
hello this is I said it's not to Johnson
this is Dwayne Johnson and paramedic
said oh no I know she's been telling us
she's a Rock's mom no listen sometimes
you got to drop that four letter word he
drops it right away
[Music]